dicas had a high fever for the past 10
days and can hardly eat together with
his mother Sarah and siblings they left
their village fleeing from Boko Haram
since then they've only had rice and
beans to eat their diet is lacking in
vitamins Siddiq's mother believes he's
ill due to lack of nutrition when i
sowwy get food here but it's not enough
twice a day there's rice and beans if we
want oil and salt we have to fend for
ourselves I'm sewing caps turn at least
a little bit of money and to help my
family make ends meet Sensei I ademas
Obama Semiahmoo Zuba why what is she
more than 200,000 people live in the
refugee camps in Borno last year almost
450 died of disease and undernourishment
only a few aid organizations are active
in the area at least the situation in
the capital Maiduguri has improved
according to the UN's children's agency
UNICEF don't forget this is really
important they newly recovered area you
can hear in the mirror that the Army is
doing a good job and gown are they've
been able to recover many areas still
those people living day we know that I
need the wire support and it will be
good you can find a way to reach the one
who can call the hard to reach zulay
melee coordinates medical efforts for
the refugees in Borno he doesn't think
it's a plot that so many children died
in refugee camps last year
don't look at the absolute numbers look
at it among how many people of severely
malnourished children do you have that
one now look at that versus what obtains
in the general population it's not much
difference but in the first few days of
course it may be higher because of what
I tell you earlier because we at that
time these people have been with the
news audience and they do not have any
form of care Sara Musa has already lost
two of her nine children she's hoping
that her son Sadiq will soon be healthy
again so that they can return to their
village it has been recaptured by the
army but outside of the state capital
the situation is still dangerous
although the security situation here in
maiduguri is slowly getting better
thousands of refugees still don't see
any improvement of the situation and the
local and national authorities in charge
of their plight are obviously still
unable to cope